Paul we're here to talk about your
latest film blood in which he star as
one of two policeman brothers who kill a
murder suspect and then have to
investigate their own crime and your
brother's played by Stephen Graham I
wondered if you could talk a bit about
developing that very important on-screen
brotherly bond yes okay I well Steven
Lee lived together during the making of
the movie and I'm really glad we did
partly because the schedule was tight
and we were able to come home I was able
to cook for him because he is unable to
cook anything except host and so and
then we would we would we would work and
I think that so there was that benefit
and also we really got to know each
other and I thought I was really
beneficial enough Steven I couldn't look
more opposite you know so and yet you I
when you see the movie I think you
really do sense a brotherly relationship
and I'm proud of that
and your father in the in the films
played by Brian Cox how did you develop
the relationship with him as well
on-screen
um well you know manie's when the film
opens he's sick in he has Alzheimer's
and is is losing his his mind and you
know so he was able to be very sort of
anarchic and spontaneous onset which I
thought was fantastic there's also a
sort of when Brian just looks at you
there's a kind of latent violence there
that he gets for nothing which is just
extraordinary and I n really serves the
film well because I am you know I think
their history with that father and a
mother who died and
was not there to protect them from their
father's rage and I think that I think
that Joe probably really you know took
his beatings and also got in the way of
any violence toward his younger brother
that's the decision that we made because
I think it really ties Stephens
character to me and makes him it's what
makes him so loyal that he can't turn
his back on his brother during this
during the story it's a very difficult
relationship as you say with your father
is that you can sense that that past
that they have that weight but in a
sense it's a very emotional and
sensitive subject now as he's saying he
has Alzheimer's and the and the brothers
are having to deal with this aren't they
I mean it as an actor is that a kind of
responsibility that you have to deal
with that subject in a way I think it
would be more so were at the main thrust
of the film I'm it is not it's a bounce
I mean my responsibility to the film was
I think you know Joe is a man I don't
think he should have been a cop frankly
I think his dad forced him into this
life that he's just not made for he he
but nevertheless he has dedicated his
life to keeping crime and Communities
separate and sees it as this sort of
civil duty to keep that disease away
from good people and then he does this
thing that is so heinous and a problem
that he simply and not that he simply
can't untie and he brings that disease
not only to the community but into his
own house to his family into his
children and I and that's devastating
for him and I think he literally you
know the he starts to unravel is really
is for me what is what the film is about
rather than it being about a
the police procedural of it you know you
know you're not actually went the the
the camera the lens isn't focused on the
procedure that they're going through to
solve the crime it's actually focused on
the sort of slow bore constrictor of
fate that is suffering and I was
wondering if because I know that as a
young man you worked for a little while
I know in a care home or a home for
healthy people didn't you know when did
you drew on any kind of experience she'd
had in you in your short time there for
how you dealt with Brian Cox's character
at all you know I think I was I hope I
was gentler you know I chose a totally
unconscious man who hasn't thought about
his mind or his past in any
introspective way you know so he knows
nothing about himself and I don't think
he's sort of questions his relationship
with his father particularly and that
was just what it was and you get on with
it and you and consequent I think that's
also why things unravel for him because
he's never sort of looked at himself but
he has a very the complicated feelings
he has for his father make it impossible
for him to really be his father's carer
and Steven takes that responsibility I
think he sensed that in the movie that
Joe can't face hasn't got the patience
for him because of what he saw his dad
do to his mother what he saw his dad do
to him and his brother he's just not got
the patience for this man and yet it has
been made by him and a vet in in in in
always for right and for wrong and and
can't escape a love for him but I
not-not-not anything in gentle or
particularly kind ladies a film that you
you made in the UK and it's a more
homegrown kind of smaller movie I guess
to some of the other movies that you've
been involved in the kind of iron man's
I know that it's your voice that's in
there as apart from your presence but
priests and films like that and lesion
and so forth and I was wondering how
important it was for you to be part of
homegrown productions like this they're
just more interesting I mean it's and I
really decided I wanted real estate back
here and I I have tried to make those
but I don't really I'm not a science
fiction watcher or an action film
watcher really I mean occasionally I
don't really know the genre I tried my
hand at it I don't think I did it very
well I don't think it's my it's not what
I excel at and so um and not say I
wouldn't try it again I just it's just
not I don't know it's not it's certainly
not where I feel I'm at at the moment
and I'm not sure I was very appropriate
for that but was interesting to try it
and I get much more of a I get much more
fulfillment from these sort of endeavors
how does it feel like when you sit down
and you watched yourself in something or
you listen to yourself in something like
one of the Iron Man movies or the
Avengers or you watch something like
priests I think I know that you kind of
always forgot that you were even in the
Avengers with Iron Man didn't you I've
never I've never seen I I haven't and
that's not because I don't know why I'm
there
that's in keeping with a lot of movies
that I've filmed and been in I haven't
I haven't I haven't seen so and I don't
know what I can't be specific about what
differentiates a movie that I do go to
see sometimes it's just fate sometimes I
get asked to come and see it sometimes I
get trapped at the premiere and I'm in
the scene and I wash it so I mean so I I
don't yeah I did then it's not like I
don't know I just um I haven't I haven't
seen
you